moi je veux devant vous prendre trois
engagements supplémentaires vis-à-vis
des collaborateurs de la
RATP d'abord comme pour les buses de
grande couronne île- de France mobilité
imposera aux nouveaux opérateurs de
maintenir les conditions sociales dont
bénéficient aujourd'hui les agents de la
RATP en effet il faut savoir que les
conditions sociales mais je pense que ça
n'est pas un mystère pour vous les
conditions sociales des agents de la
RATP sont supérieures à celles aux
conditions sociales socle qui sont fixés
par le décret du cadre social
territorial et qui s'applique donc aux
autres opérateurs français donc le sujet
c'était est-ce que on peut demander de
maintenir les conditions sociales de la
RATP pour les agents qui sont déjà
salariés de la RATP c'est ce qu' de
France mobilité demandera dans ses
appels d'offre aux nouveaux opérateurs
ce qui permet évidemment de
tranquilliser des agents notamment sur
des régimes de retraite qui sont un peu
spécifiques et cetera
ensuite j'ai décidé que les conditions
sociale serait préservé les conditions
sociales de la RATP seraiit préservé
pour l'ensemble des machinistes des
dépôts de bus quelle que soit la ligne
de bus alors c'est un peu technique mais
il se trouve que l'État je ne sais pas
pourquoi dans sa grande sagesse avait
exclu certains territoires du cadre
social territorial en fait l'État a pris
un périmètre du cadre social territorial
qui est plus petit que le réseau RATP
existant il y a des lignes RATP en
dehors du cadre social territorial
évidemment les agents qui sont sur ces
lignes qui sont en dehors du cadre
social territorial donc je n'ai pas
compris pourquoi il ne reprenaient pas
les le tracé des 13 des 13 lot RATP mais
enfin bon typiquement des agents qui
sont en en en bordure de la Grande
Couronne ne serait pas concerné par le
cadre social territorial nous les
réintégrons et nous demanderons aux
opérateurs qu'il soient traités comme
les agents du cadre social territorial
et enfin sur la sécurité du réseau parce
que c'est très important évidemment
on va inclure dans les nouveaux contrats
de DSP de délégation de service public
l'obligation pour l'opérateur de
recruter des agents de sécurité
supplémentair donc ça c'est pour donner
un j'allais dire un plus encore à la
sécurité sur le réseau pourquoi parce
que la RATP a un service le GPSR qui est
un service de sécurité global pour
l'ensemble de l'entreprise et donc il y
avait une petite angoisse notamment des
opérateurs alternatifs mais aussi les
agents queil y ait moins d'agents de
sûreté du coup sur les réseaux si
c'était plus opéré par la RATP